depuis presque deux ans le même rituel
pour se protéger de l'ennemi invisible
et depuis des mois le même scénario un
patient non vaccinés foudroyés par l'aco
vide et soigné à grands frais aux soins
intenses et les patients très malades
beaucoup de non vaccinés ou des vaccinés
immunocompromises depuis noël le nombre
de patients qu'ovide aux soins intensifs
a plus que triplé il occupe maintenant
21 des 30 lits si tu es juste neuf lits
sur 30 pour admettre le reste ben tu es
moins du reste le reste étant des
chirurgies cardiaques cancers et plus de
cas tellement que certains médicaments
contre lacko vide commencent à manquer
qui est vraiment ce problème là le qui
fait qu'avec le nombre de cas de
beaucoup de traitement de données puis
l'on me manque de ces médicaments
un étage plus bas la docteure vicky
soulière participent à la réunion
quotidienne où l'on cherche des
solutions
d'autres hôpitaux devront prendre des
patients sacré qu'un rapproche du point
de saturation
et contrairement aux vagues précédentes
le problème ne touche plus seulement les
soins intensifs
on compte beaucoup plus de cas bénins ce
qui submerge d'autres départements comme
ici la pneumologie donc on a commencé
par remplir un peu les charmes du fond
on les a laissés un peu à part puis
progressivement au fur et à mesure
qu'elles aient conscience vanter
on a fini par rentrer et remplir le
modèle au complet une soixantaine de
lits depuis nos logis transformer un
leak au vide on isole des patients qui
ne sont pas très malade et qui pour la
plupart ont appris à l'hôpital qu'ils
étaient infectés la moitié des communes
viennent pas pour la cave ils viennent
pour autre chose qu'on rattrape la coved
tacon jacques pas de la corvée dont jaar
d isolement un peu c'est parce que c'est
la vague la gestion d isolement d
isolement des patients qui viennent pour
autre chose et les allemands des
travailleurs de la santé qui sont aussi
aux prises avec sa réduire la
quarantaine des travailleurs est l'une
des solutions ça se peut qu'on puisse
lever d'isolement aujourd'hui on attend
juste à côté en cardiologie situation
semblable la moitié des lits sont
occupés par des patients infectés par
l'aco vide présentement 12 litres de 4,8
positif de 24 donc c'est vraiment le 50
% de notre département deco vite
positive de toutes les spécialités et
avec le retour en classe la nervosité
augmente
il ya beaucoup de travailleurs de la
santé qui ont des enfants l'écologie
mais on ne peut la chienne je pourrai
connaître loti de devoir les corps et
augmenter on se creuse de cinquième
vague difficile de voir comment on
pourra éventuellement combler le retard
accumulé et c'est qu'il va falloir
rattraper tout le retard qu'on a pris
alors qu'on va être tout le monde est
rappelons un peu je pense que l'été les
prochains mois ou moins difficiles mais
même une fois la vague passé ici david
gêne-t-il et radio canada montréal